[Music]
in butwhy news may I know why submitted
by lo Junior ROTC members have been
suspended after they branded a fellow
student with a hot iron oh you little
[ __ ] walk down wait wait they do that
it was just a hazing ritual right seems
like it that sucks
yeah but that [ __ ] I spent leave a scar
for there's your life a lot of those
fraternities from the south do it - it's
crazy fraternity well is it in high
school oh I'm not saying it's right or
anything but it's crazy the ROTC kids
supposed to be like the like kids like
the big nerds like if somebody was like
oh yeah he's an ROTC I'd be like I'm to
see kids doing that they were like very
straightforward like upright citizens
yeah I mean except for a few pieces of
[ __ ] in there but they were doing that
because they knew that they want to go
the military later so it kind of helped
them out later on my high school the we
made the national news because the
baseball team hey is the new guy by
shoving a baseball bat up the guy's ass
did he die
no he live yeah it was like a huge story
what end though this truth make you're
holding in a laughs no no no yeah I
never believed in our high school you
can lose what end they never tell you
that [ __ ] in the stories you never like
the business end of the pace of hope we
had a field correspondent they would be
like okay but I can't come I can't go
back to my I can't go back to the
station without finding out what end do
they know you've been the smaller in
because I had line means like different
be like high school students but hole
was slaughtered by large end of a
baseball bat yeah because the small one
is like it's like not that bad I mean
it's not that bad that's pretty bad
that's pretty bad but not as bad did I
take a big Dookie like a month ago and
that [ __ ] tore my ass I bled a little
bit so mad into the bottom yeah was it
it was at the top in the baddest mom I
just remember it was really light when I
[ __ ] I went and then I saw I wiped and I
saw a little blood and I looked it up
online I was I get what the [ __ ] I did
you said I'd really hard Dukey and
happened sometimes it's not a big deal
you gotta stop looking [ __ ] up online
dude I wanted to see if I if I had to go
to the [ __ ] what's it called urgent
care or something oh my god it's just
like if you have a lot of fun
how do you go to urge your brother you
know dude I put something so big and
hard but I tore my ass like you got
[ __ ] in the ass no no no no no is that
what you call your boyfriend food yeah
so he's a Junior ROTC guys a rhotic hey
Brandon it has been disbanded the sixth
place in Queens it disbanded after
cadets branded a fellow member the hot
iron on the butt oh these girls are boys
I have to be boys gotta be boys yeah I'm
assuming because if it was a guy that
pinned a girl yeah boys over dude it
sounds like boy behavior yeah they
didn't find out until the parents of the
kid somehow found out because this
happened in the summer but they just
recently found this out Oh was he okay
with it or he told his parents I go this
is like some [ __ ] that's been happening
I'm not sure how the parents found out
what they did because if the kid was
like hey Dad guess what you're the
homies Brandon my [ __ ] was crazy
ah you know that he's like it's a part
of the group thing like he likes it
probably wasn't something don't I'm one
of the brand was yeah well it wasn't
like the wu-tang somewhere something
just as fresh principles I've been
trying to draw that W for like two years
of my junior are you serious I wanted to
perfect that I couldn't get it make a
block look no it's a curvy look look I
already drew it look you talk it will
have a diluting simplifying content
so me and Nikki we're at the pumpkin
patch two nights ago
mom dad and three kids all had wu-tang's
shirts on it was incredible it was a
glimpse into your future it was it was
did the mom have an M&M shirt that would
be your future oh that's true that's a
good point it's so interesting how much
she likes M&M it's yeah it's weird
Mickey said that she was just thinking
about the scenario of her meeting Eminem
in the future at some point and she just
started crying I just the idea of like
ever meeting him well no so I took her
to an mm concert you took her to meet
the competition I'm a good guy right I
like my wife right so I might so when we
got together I set it up through YouTube
to have us through maker studios to have
his phone to New York where we got to go
to the YouTube Music Awards or whatever
the [ __ ] that was where Eminem was
performing hmm and I surprised her with
this [ __ ] and then when we showed up she
didn't even know that she was this huge
Eminem raving wig fangirl thing until he
came on stage and she started bawling
child
yeah like tyka fell down I think is it
like
like that [ __ ] did and so she had even
know how she was know broke up for two
weeks because you're so embarrassed and
then what happened I thought it was
hilarious to I just thought it was so
funny did she cry for the whole thing
yeah basically the whole time he was up
there yeah well the real Slim Shady
please daddy did die I'm gonna kill my
wife song yeah so the whole thing was
directed by Spike Jonze
yeah so Eminem the whole time was never
facing the audience one time so all she
saw the family's [ __ ] heads go like
this [ __ ] to a camera and he never
turned around one time and she was still
bawling like that Wow had she ever been
to an Eminem concert before she had but
she'd never been like this close to the
guy that dude still looks so [ __ ]
young it son really does you got the
just for men beard a little too yeah for
sure oh yeah that's a good skin regimen
[ __ ] it's nice yeah and that took her to
another concert where we were front row
and close and she did the same [ __ ] she
was long but she wasn't balling the
whole time who is that Eminem Eminem oh
okay are you gonna take her again apart
not if he goes around again sure I
appointed is there anybody that you guys
like like celebrity why's that if you
saw them and they said to you like hey
my name is xxx I love your work would
you man right man Oh fret man oh this is
that red man cool he's had a [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of Bart so no before no Bart's
gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of Pratt I'm
okay with either way it's fine mine is
DMX yeah man I've been trying me DMX for
like 10 you can't be hard anymore no
what the [ __ ] do you love about DMX so
much because he's just I don't know
fine huh I told your dog's about [ __ ]
would be driver told me a story like DMX
came on like in in the car and then like
like I got from this 30 minute ride just
sitting back there then I started
humming I was like you know and he was
like he was like you like do Mexi turn
it off
and that's a song he was like he was
like I am DMX he was like I was in a
department store one time and I was just
walking around and I heard this really
familiar voice and it was it said $500
it's gonna suck my dick and he was like
it but he did him DMX voice he turns
around and it's [ __ ] dear Mac
something that's my boy that's my boy I
loved DMX like button I loved DMX also
DMX in a store disputing the prize
that's really my favorite [ __ ] DMX
song and I can't even sing it out loud
because he says the n-bomb seven times
in the beginning huh
what a dot want to try and I can't even
say it out in public
yeah I love Steven Seagal and a huge fan
student Segal ironically an ironic Lee
and our to our boys did a film together
a feature-length film all right
was it like a buddy cop movie no no
they're both in prison together they're
in Alcatraz together yeah it's like
Steven Segal looking fatter than [ __ ] in
here just like his but in jail and like
they they help each other escape from
prison
oh my god it's like the opposite of a
buddy cop movie but I've always wanted
to see DMX in a buddy cop movie we
should do a movie night and we'll watch
half past tense even sick you could go
on Netflix right now and he has a bunch
of shitty like [ __ ] films
literally every film there's somebody
talking about how dope he is so it a
little bit like this so Steve Scott
walks in the room and there's like a
just said that he goes are you like Jack
the Ripper or that's just like name and
he goes yep he goes so you're a man who
has seven years of martial arts killed
3,000 men and also has a huge dick
always he always tries to talk in this
like mystical Louisiana accent now like
that's his new thing is like he he he he
would he was a policeman in Louisiana is
it he yeah exactly so he feels like he's
like a Louisiana now and so he ever in
every movie he's always like well that's
not exactly what we talked about out
here it's really weird it's like the
same segoe we've all known but he
changes my [ __ ] roommate he does like
sound and audio [ __ ] so they had to
record ADR for one of his films right so
check how [ __ ] like weird this dude is
so here's the [ __ ] Phil bright and he
has to do ADR so he comes in and they're
like alright mr. Seagal we need you say
these lines and he does it once super
fast right okay mr. Seagal we need you
to redo this because you just mumbled
through the lines you're like you did in
movies they had to get a Steven Seagal
impersonator know come in and do his
voice what an honor and the stew and
they sent it in and the people who are
directly got mad because they said the
Steven Seagal voice actor was to was to
clear the way that he was it was it was
too perfect
dude the best is the way they do they
light all his new shake do you're
talking about his shitty movies the way
to think like that [ __ ] is like you can
just see a Batman movie but he never
like lifts a leg or nothing now yeah and
then and then it just cuts to like a
pretty cut guy like doing a [ __ ]
straight kick all the way up yeah it's
amazing if you guys are ever bored just
look up Steven Seagal running oh yeah
that is good he has the funniest run
ever dude it's great wait have you guys
ever heard him because you're talking
about the celebrity ADR how there's like
in big films like I think it was George
Clooney I saw this on a plane and how
there's different people in countries
that are like a voice of George Clooney
for dubbing and they're known as like I
am the George Clooney of India I'm the
George Clooney of
Singapore yeah and like they do like all
these interviews and they get all this
like crazy money and all this pain
because they're like I am the voice of
George Clooney that's that's some real
[ __ ] this is Bruce Willis he doesn't do
his own he doesn't stand in for himself
and he also doesn't do it on ATR there's
somebody else that doesn't mom he goes
Bruce Willis wow that sounds like a
Bruce Willis thing yes so if it's like a
shot where psych is over the shoulder
that somebody officer stands in for and
the first year and then after that his
ADR he doesn't do it himself
he's looking to the script exciting this
is over the shoulder bring and Tommy
yeah
[Music]
you